sabías que a partir de una figura
geométrica simple podemos formar una más
compleja es muy fácil se puede hacer con
un triángulo con un cuadrado un
pentágono o un hexágono lo intentamos
saca lápiz y papel
con pausa el vídeo dibujo un triángulo
como este y cuando lo tengas continúa
viendo el vídeo
lo que haremos ahora es tomar este
triángulo que dibujamos y lo vamos a
llevar a otro punto con mucha atención
lo único que tenemos que hacer es trazar
una copia del triángulo pero esta vez lo
dibujaremos un poco en diagonal a un
lado justo así al hacer esto las medidas
de los lados y sus ángulos deben de
seguir iguales cuida que conserven sus
medidas para poder identificar sus
vértices escribimos una letra en cada
uno de ellos yo pondré a b y c
identifican los vértices en tu figura
en la segunda figura haremos lo mismo
recuerda poner la misma letra para el
vértice correspondiente
y si unimos sus vértices o sea con a b
con b y se conoce que queréis que ocurra
vamos a averiguarlo
wow se forma una nueva figura seguro a
ti te quedó mejor con una regla sabes
qué figura es muy bien es un prisma y un
prisma no es más que un cuerpo
geométrico que tiene dos bases iguales
el número de caras será el número de
lados que tenga la figura de la base el
prisma que formamos con las figuras
iniciales tiene caras en forma de
rectángulos como a mis dos bases son
triángulos tengo tres caras por ejemplo
si la base fuera un cuadrado tendríamos
dos bases cuadradas y por lo tanto
cuatro caras super fácil no crees hay
algo más que debes saber la altura de
nuestro prisma es igual a la distancia
que hay entre cada triángulo y la puedes
medir con una línea que va de b a b es
decir la línea de un vértice a otro
te voy a dibujar algunos ejemplos para
que veas si tu prisma está bien trazado
este sería un prisma cuadrangular
este un pentagonal y este de aquí un
hexagonal
ahora descubriremos otro cuerpo
geométrico que también es muy fácil de
dibujar y que estoy segura que ya
conoces
dibujamos de nuevo un triángulo listo
esta vez pongamos un punto fuera de la
figura lo dibujaremos aquí arriba pero
no es una regla los puntos se pueden
ubicar en cualquier lugar alrededor de
la figura pero siempre afuera como en el
ejemplo anterior vamos a identificar
cada uno de sus vértices
y ahora simplemente trazamos una línea
de cada vértice hacia el punto que
acabamos de dibujar yo trazar una línea
de a al punto debe al punto y desde al
punto ya atrás hace tus líneas desde
cada vértice al punto
perfecto sabes cómo se llama este cuerpo
de geométrico
es una pirámide las bases las caras de
una pirámide siempre son triangulares y
se unen en un vértice en común que se
llama cúspide
si queremos saber cuánto mide de alto
nuestra pirámide simplemente medimos la
distancia que hay del centro de la base
hasta la cúspide al igual que los
prismas el nombre de las pirámides se
define por la forma de su base entonces
puede ser una pirámide triangular
cuadrangular
pentagonal hexagonal y más
te voy a dar unos tips para que los
prismas y pirámides no te confundan
recuerda que siempre recibirán su nombre
de acuerdo a la forma que tienen sus
bases y hablando de bases no olvides que
los prismas tienen dos bases y las
pirámides sólo una otro tipo las caras
de los prismas siempre serán
rectangulares y las de las pirámides
triangulares y por si esto no fuera
suficiente las pirámides tienen cúspide
y los prismas no
por último te propongo un reto haz una
lista con los prismas que vayas viendo
todos los días te aseguro que
encontrarás muchísimos las pirámides son
un poco más difíciles de encontrar pero
no te des por vencido que también hay
varias buscarlas